all right tanya
tanya where are you from where'd you
grow up la
south central yeah and tell me about
your uh your family had both your
parents growing up
not really died when i was
my father hasn't really been in my life
since about six
my mom died when i was very young your
mom died
yeah i'm sorry where was dad
just out of the picture yeah he was um
battling addiction always so
who raised you um
the village so did you go to the foster
system or
no we see the village
everybody just takes a village to raise
your child the neighbors
people you know people you meet in your
life so not even family just neighbors
and friends
um a couple family
like an aunt or two we bounced around
yeah i was all over young hurt
parents gone super young
what kind of kid were you in high school
good kid cheerleader
um rotc oh good
was there any abuse when you were
growing up no
no then you went out on your own at what
age
13.
you went to the street
when you worked figara currently when
did you start working the stream
well after like my mom passed like
i was lost plus you know my aunt did the
best she could do
people you know but i was always raised
like you know you got to
get your own i see examples in front of
me you know nobody wants to take care of
nobody else especially if it's not their
own so
i had to live i had to eat you know
what age did you start working as a
prostitute about 14
14. you worked on your own or with a
pimp
um i've had
people to look out for me but mainly on
my own because i was just one of those
no i don't understand giving you all my
money no
no i'm trying to live and take care of
me and find my way i'm not giving you my
money
for what for you just to
watch me i can watch myself i'm doing
the work
i'm gonna keep it for myself
have you been arrested for this
how many times
10 15. wow
you ever had any bad experiences with
the guys that pick you up
um yeah rob
um picked up and
dropped off somewhere way out the
district
by the grace of god never been seriously
injured or
you know raped or not like that but i
know a lot of people who have
and it's a scary world scary life i
wouldn't recommend anybody
to go that way
so do you have any family to stay in
contact with now
so i do but
i really distanced myself from a lot of
people
my mom died
it did a lot to me caused a lot of
emotional pain
because i was a child and i didn't
understand
so
you know i just did my own thing
did my own thing are drugs a part of the
picture for you
i have tampered with you know
a little bit here a little bit there but
drinking mainly drinking this
does this lifestyle get you down
sometimes of course it would it's like
you're selling your body on the street
to man
not because sometimes you want to do it
because like
well i know i can get the money for this
for that so that's what i'm gonna do but
is it right should you be no
you shouldn't and it's definitely i
should have had
somebody older to guide me and support
me
in the direction instead of letting me
free will
yeah you like that guidance as a kid oh
yeah
did you did you have friends doing the
same thing
maybe one or two but not really they all
still was
kids at home with their parents getting
punishments
and all that [ __ ] sneaking out running
away i never had a chance to like sneak
out and run away
and get caught before the street lights
came on like [ __ ]
oh my god just past curfew damn i stayed
not at the party too long i never
i did what i wanted did you stay up all
night i did what i went to
club got home i did everything
you have kids of your own i have a son
and are you raising him
um not at this second i was
but things happened in life that
something's just out our control
not saying i'm a bad parent just life
gets hard sometimes you may get a
curveball thrown at you where is it
who's raising him now
family
what was the best time of your life
i have a lot of best times you know
childhood before my mom passed was great
my son great um
understanding that everything isn't your
fault
put a smile on my face that you don't
have to feel
embarrassed or shameful for what you're
going through
what you had to go through because
i mean life ain't easy
but i mean better i'm trying to make it
better
that's what i know as long as you're
trying to work towards better
that's what counts but it's not going to
be easy you're going to go through a lot
like they say i go through a lot of pain
and hurt to get to the happy days
i mean i can't cry over spilled milk
what was the worst time of your life
being on the streets
sleepy tired
my mom dying i'm dying
have you been in love before
yes
i have your
father your child no no
childhood love
still knowing still in love with them
like i first met him when i was a kid
brings me joy happiness
it's not easy but how old are you now
no oh you don't look old
i'm a little old i'm in my 30s
how do you think this life is changing
it helped me understand more
it helped me want more it opened my eyes
i'm kind of glad i experienced it
i've been through it going through it
because i don't know
sometimes you need to go to struggle and
to see what you really got out there i
mean some people may say that sounds
stupid but
everybody wasn't handed a spoon and got
money and family do this and do that my
life is hard
it still is hard but
knowing now it's a it's a different way
out
i knew it was a different way out as a
kid but i didn't know because i was a
kid
but i don't regret it though
do i regret being prostitute no i don't
i agree anything i've done
maybe a few things but no
no really it's going to make me to be
the strong individual that i am
did you have dreams of a different life
when you were a young girl
what did you want to do be a housewife
with a job
and be a mother but i wanted to be a
cook
and a beautician
that's me doing here and cooking and
have
two maybe three kids and the husband
be there at home cooking cleaning taking
care of the kids make sure my husband
got what he need he's satisfied he's not
one for nothing
but still i'ma get up and go to work
because i need to make my money
my cheers that can all still happen
you're still young
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you in this lifestyle
isn't your son is it because you're
working the street that that
happened
i am i mean i refuse to go or hear my
son ever say
he don't have i can't do for him because
i can do anything
i don't care what it's what it'll take
i'll do anything
to make sure my son is
not without ever
i don't care what nobody says
nobody and i do have a lot of pride with
asking people for handouts and this now
imma get it on my own
that's my child that's mine he belongs
to me
so therefore it's my responsibility
because i can ask somebody for something
but
well they have a choice i don't
because he's mine so i'll do whatever it
takes and if i have to do it today again
for my child i'll do whatever yes
[Music]
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you
you